kidnap normal folk like us where'd they
get you from Wyoming Mississippi Lando
and Hannes for sport we were the first
to tell you earlier this week about that
NBC Universal movie and now they're
facing some backlash we're moving
forward with this controversial film the
hunt the film is about wealthy liberals
hunting and killing deplorable zs-- on a
reserve the studio pulled ads for the
film after the El Paso and Dayton
shootings but a source told Fox News
quote there are no plans to not release
the movie double negative no plans to
move the release will this be a decision
they come to regret joining me now is
actor Robert Davi now Robert thanks for
being here
you have starred in your share of
gorillas die hard the Bond movies
Universal says the hunt is a satire your
thoughts on the cultural impact of this
film being released at this moment you
know the cultural impact Hollywood has a
responsibility on its cultural impact to
society and what we just saw what
happened in Dayton Ohio and in Texas
what we saw happened in Las Vegas which
was a shooting gallery for someone that
we don't know much about what happened
there do we and to do a film at this
particular time listen freedom of speech
freedom of art culture I like that I
like people being able to express
themselves but there's this
responsibility to culture how many kids
are responsive who knows who kidnapped
who a group of people and say let's have
fun
now I haven't seen the film I've just
heard the controversial about it but the
filmmakers have done controversial films
before that Craig Zobel has done
compliance which was about a female
being abused in a McDonald's or
something to that effect that people at
Sundance walked out on but and and and
the other jason blum and his company
they did whiplash and it was a financial
failure but it won the Oscar but he did
another film that was very successful
that was very controversial now there's
a responsibility in in our business to
not have this something like this happen
well I went for I think when we know
these mass shooters respond to violent
imagery
to set up a picture where you have
Americans hunting other Americans this
is problematic the president seemed to
talk about the hunt today watch this
you talk about races Hollywood is racist
what they're doing with the kind of
movies they're putting out it's actually
very dangerous for our country what
Hollywood is doing is a tremendous
disservice to our country robert davi
the filmmakers of the hunt claim that
the liberal elite hunters get their
comeuppance when the deplorable --zz
turned the table on them but why is it
acceptable to kill your political
adversaries whether right or left
isn't that normalizing political murder
homicide it's look it's wrong both ways
it you know I mean imagine having a film
where people are kidnapping Muslims or
black people or Italians and having a
shooting gallery and they I mean it's a
no or Jews it's a no-win film you I
don't care if there's comeuppance
we shouldn't be propagating that in
society it's so dangerous people out
there in our society have problems the
mental illness yeah this will affect
someone and someone who who knows what I
did it might generate from this film
it's just not the kind of entertainment
we should be doing well it's a poisonous
idea and we've been hearing a lot
politically about the rhetoric people
use in that how that leads to bad ends
why don't potent images and storylines
far more persuasive than anything
someone says why isn't that considered
also a variable here right we have to
move on to this up you know what Lenin
said about you know you know what they
said about cinema it was the most
important tool for propaganda hmm well
let's pray it's not but I I fear you're
right Robert I want to move on to this
uproar over billionaire Steven Ross he
hosted that big fundraiser for Trump's
re-election campaign today a few
protesters lined the streets outside his
Hampton New York home today but the real
backlash comes from celebrities like
Chrissy Teigen and Michael Moore calling
for people to cancel their equinox and
solstice because we Ross is an investor
in those overpriced gyms what's really
going on here how does canceling a gym
member
ship stop an administration you might
disagree with again it's the wrong idea
we can't be doing this to each other in
the nation we should be doing things to
unify you mean to tell me that anyone
that supports someone else and gives
money to a campaign you know this is
this is taking it to the next level
George Soros how many how much money has
he given to people the Koch brothers and
other organizations how much money has
Bob Iger from Disney given to the
Democratic campaign or Katzenberg are we
gonna start boycotting every business
that gives money here and gives money
there it's it's a no-win situation now
and I disagree with it we have free do
what you want want to do it so it's the
politicization of everything Robert
everything and the president ended up
hauling 12 million dollars at these two
fundraisers today two million more than
first reported now piggybacking off of
what you were just saying actor Armie
Hammer is also jumping on the same train
he's calling out a major entertainment
executive supporting Trump tweeting hey
while everyone seems to be on the
Equinox thing it might be a good time to
mention that one of trumps largest
financial contributors is chairman of
Marvel Entertainment Isaac Perlmutter
just saying Robert this seems to me it
seems to me that this is the real hunt
and attempt to purge anyone from
Hollywood who might support someone that
the majority disagrees with there I
think people should Google Arm and
Hammer who spent many years in the
Soviet Union and Armand Hammer who said
to Al Gore senior I will make your son
Al jr. President of the United States I
mean there is a culture and I've met
army ham and he's a nice guy but again
this is freedom this is what happens to
our democracy Raymond what's happening
to our democracy if people are afraid to
if they peel off votes if kids are
afraid to vote or speak their mind it
does have an effect these celebrities do
have an effect and it's it's probably
responsible to do that before I let you
go 30 seconds tell me very quickly about
this core idea you have almost a
neighborhood watch as a result of these
mass shootings we've seen well since
2001 I was on Homeland Security Policy
Institute at
George Washington University when I saw
the things happening and people not
knowing what to do I came up with an
idea that at Homeland Security they did
a white paper to protect the critical
infrastructure and the soft targets of
America civilian patrol 93 based on
those guys that in Pennsylvania cook
took the plane and went into the ground
it's something right now that can help
this nation the woman in San Diego that
saw something and was afraid to say it
yeah because of political correctness a
civilian patrol 93 and it's much more
nuanced than 30 than 30 seconds it's not
weaponry it's an intelligence for the
communities to work kotas with law
enforcement
they are sensitized they are the small
background check but we need eyes and
ears in our community it will save lives
robert davi i thank you so much i hope
people pursue the idea i know you've
written about it at length thank you for
being here